everyone I'm Kristen Gill and you're
watching how to Hollywood today I have
the wonderful Kelly Baker you may know
her as Kelly Baker brows the brow queen
of Hollywood we are going to show you
how to get a list brows she has
celebrity clients like Scindia Khloe
Kardashian Shay Mitchell fifth harmony
all the girls all the girls of Hollywood
the list goes on so if you guys want to
learn how to recreate Kelly's a list
brows then please keep watching the most
important part of filling in your brows
is always use a highlighter most
important part okay okay so what we're
gonna do we have two ways of doing it
typically people will just draw right
underneath mm-hmm but I have learned a
new trick that makes it super easy for
you guys you're gonna take your smudge
brush and you're gonna take your
highlighter and we're just gonna do one
little swipe right in the tip of the
highlighter pencil and we're gonna go
right underneath your brow with a smudge
brush and this is gonna create a nice
line and basically the whole point of it
is to lift your brows and brighten up
the eye area but it's a really cool
trick because whether people woman has
makeup on or no makeup on it's an easy
way just to give you an instant little
pick-me-up so like in between visits it
will cover up your brow hair so it makes
it look like they're not extra furry so
we're just going to smudge it right up
to the hairline and this is actually
gonna make it look brows look fuller and
more defined why you use a smudger brush
versus like an angled brush or something
because it's gonna give you that nice
extra definition a lot of times people
don't realize that if you just use the
highlighter you're not gonna get that
nice line so you could draw it on and
you can smudge it in with your fingers
but you're not gonna get that pop that
everyone is looking for so now we're
gonna go into the powder I'm gonna go
ahead and use a blonde powder and my
angle brush on her we're gonna take one
tap that is all we need and we're gonna
go right on the inside of the brow right
where the brow hits that highlighter
line very very soft I like to tell
everyone less is more and you'll see it
start to build you can already see it's
starting to fill up and this is blonde
now you have you
blonde hair and your brows are darker
which I do like I like that everyone's
brows tend to be a shade darker but the
way to make them look natural when you
fill them in is to by using a shade
lighter okay so you have brown brows
using blonde to make them look like they
belong to you oh I like that nice trick
yes so I'm gonna go ahead and take my
smudge brush and just kind of clean up
the top part of the line just a little
bit so you guys can also use this as an
eraser if you need to smooth out any
area and remember it is art it's never
gonna be totally perfect what's the
difference between you doing like a
regular brow someone coming in versus
doing a brow for a red carpet typically
for a red carpet we'll do a little bit
more makeup yeah
just because they will be you know
photographed mm-hmm
so but it also just depends on the
client and what their look is Shay
Mitchell say she's getting ready for a
red carpet Patrick toss for makeup
artist yes
he hates doing brows he does do you go
in and help him do the brows and then
leave it kind of depends on the
situation
Patrick actually introduced me to Shay
and to the handful of my celeb clients
he's the best and basically what it does
is introduces me to his client so I
could do the brows and then you know
makes it like you much either so much
easier so it just kind of depends on
what the event is and if I'm around
lately I've been doing some work with
the Kardashians and it's fun because
I'll show up and Patricks there so I'm
doing Patrick's brows their brows
everyone is brows it's a whole brow
party glam team so now we're just doing
the same thing again we're using the
blonde powder and you guys can see how
soft and natural her brows look they
just open up her eyes and that is pretty
much it we highlighted the light
highlighter to lift the brow bone and we
filled it in with a blonde powder and it
looks fab oh my gosh look at you you
work your magic so quick I you know I
try
so I want to know how did you get
started in brows
I first started off doing makeup then
went to beauty school and was taught how
to do brows and I'm also a Virgo
perfectionist a lot of you guys have
heard this so straight lines is like
pretty much my thing so once I learned
how to do it I was like I got this like
this is easy for me so now is it and
that was 15 years ago
you have your salon yep in Venice yep on
a bikini and I started in Beverly Hills
so okay I got lucky and started in a
really cool place with some really cool
people tell me someone you really enjoy
working with that you maybe started out
with like early on I think my longest
right now is both been a Mitchell and
zendaya the one the only person that I
love to touch my brows because they are
the most important thing on my face I've
been working with both of them for about
four years so it's been really cool to
see how much they've grown I mean
they've already been famous for quite
some time but I mean even before you
know I met zendaya I have a little boy
and we used to watch her on TV and I
started to see her brow start to change
like she was messing with them so I was
like oh my god one day I need to do her
brows and then I met her we just
celebrated her 21st birthday I love them
I love everyone but it's been it's been
a fun ride and now brow clean like
everybody it wants Kellie Baker brows I
mean I'm happy that you know it's become
a look and it's recognized though and
you have your own line what was it like
crazy yeah well again the Virgo and me
you know it unless it's perfect you guys
will never see it my whole goal was to
make sure that everyone at home can do
it themselves
yeah that's all that I really care about
and of course we guys want to shop it's
available at Kobe brows calm three
shades blonde brown dark brown that way
it covers every skin tone every
ethnicity anyone that walks in the
building or sits in my chair I can take
care of and happy I just wanted to thank
you so much for being here and thank you
this is so quick and everyone can do it
themselves so if you guys have any
questions for us make sure to comment
down below if you have any questions on
any more tips and tricks that Kelly can
do I will shoot them her way and make
sure to subscribe to our Channel and I
will see you in the next one bye guys